معنا من دونيت كان مراسله الجزيره سلام
خضر ومن خرسون مراسل الجزيره تامر الصمادي
وسنبدا من خرسون وما اذا كان القصف المكثف
خلال الساعه الماضيه مستمرا تامر
القصف لا يهدا لا يتوقف وانا اتحدث اليك
الان القصف ايضا يتجدد
يتجدد في هذه الاثناء في محيط نهر دنيبر
التي تشهد مواجهات مستعيره بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه تواجد الان في احد
اجزاء الميناء النهري في المدينه هذا
الميناء الجزء من نهر دنيبر والضفه تحديدا
التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الاوكرانيه هذه
المنطقه هذا المكان تعرض اليوم لقصف من
قبل القوات الروسيه تحديدا المستودعات
الاغذيه كما قالت القوات الاوكرانيه
العديد من المستودعات الاغذيه في الميناء
تعرضت للقصف يستطيع المصور ان
ياتيكم الصوره صوره همم سنه الله التي لا
زالت تتصاعد في هذا المكان قالت السلطات
منذ الصباح بان هذا المستودع او هذه
المستود هي جزء همم من اماكن تخزن فيها
المواد الغذائيه في المدينه في الحقيقه
القصف متواصل الاصوات كثيفه هنا تسمع في
قلب المدينه القصف الروسيه تواصل على
المدينه وعلى العديد من القرى والبلدات
الواقعه على خط التماس وهنالك قصف مدفع
يتجدد يتجدد يتجدد الان وانا اتحدث اليك
بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه تقول
القوات الاوكرانيه بانها تقصف اماكن تمركز
القوات الروسيه على الضفه الشرقيه من نهر
دنيبر تقول ايضا
لا اعلم لا اعلم من كثره التثبيت معك تامر
امين
منذ يومين ماذا عن وضع السكان والمدنيين
هناك خصوصا وانا نعلم ان المدينه تعيش في
ظلام دامس قطعت عنها كهرباء بفعل القصف في
ظل همم طبعا طقس بارد وقارب كمان يمكننا
ان نرى
يتجدد يتجدد يتجدد انسي القصف عنيف جدا في
المحيط الذي نقف فيه عنيف جدا هنالك قصف
مدفعي ونستطيع ان نميز هذه الاصوات هذه
مدفعيه اوكرانيه
المكوث الطويل هنا في خير الايام طويله
نستطيع ان نؤكد بان هذه الاصوات الان مره
اخرى الان مره اخرى هذه
نعم السي هذه الاصوات تصدر من هنا ال ال
ال المدفعيه الاوكرانيه تواصل ضرب مواقع
تمركز القوات الروسيه على الضفه الاخرى من
نهر دنبر القوات الروسيه ايضا تقصف
سالتيني عن الوضع الانساني لا ما لا
كهرباء لا اتصالات الا في حدودها الدنيا
الخدمات منقطعه بشكل كبير السلطات منذ
ايام ومنذ اكثر من اسبوع وهي تواصل
مناشدتها لمن تبقى من سكان في المدينه
بضروره الاخلاء الى مقاطعه وسط وغرب
اوكرانيا الاقل تضررا بالحرب بالقصف وهذه
المدينه في الحقيقه ايس كان يسكنها قبل
الحرب اكثر من 300,000 نسمه الان لم يبقى
منهم الا القليل القليله الايام الماضيه
والسلطات توفر قطارات حافلات كبيره لنقل
الراغبين بالنزوح وتناشد وتؤكد على ضروره
النزوح نحن منذ الصباح نتجول على الضفه
اليمنى حيث يسمح لنا بالوصول الى اقرب
النقاط الكثير من المنازل اخليت من السكان
تحديدا المناطق القريبه من النهر وكثير من
المنازل قصف بالفعل وتضرر نتيجه القصف
المتبادل بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه
ادي لنستطيع القول بان خيرسون اليوم جبهه
مفتوحه بين
اوكران والروس والقصف متواصل حتى هذه
الحيطه شكرا
تبقى معنا ستحول الى دنياتك من هناك معنا
همم سلام خضر سلام اذا قتلى وجرح بفعل
القصف الاخرانيه على دنيا حسب الروايه
الروسيه ماذا في التفاصيل
السي اربعه قتله وعدد من الجرحى قالت
سلطات المحليه انهم سقطوا نتيجه القصف
الاوكراني طبعا الضحايا سقطوا سواء هنا في
مدينه دانيتس التي تتعرض الاحياء الداخليه
لهذه المدينه لقصف المستمر من الجانب
الاوكراني وان كانت حده القصف اليوم يمكن
ان نصفها بانها اقل مقارنه مع ما شهدته
المدينه يوم امس يوم امس كان قاسيا على
مدينه دانيات سقطت اكثر من 200 و30 قذيفه
وصاروخ بحسب السلطات المحليه اما ميدانيا
فلا عارك ما تزال مستمر وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اعلنت قبل دقائق عن ان وحداتها قد
حقق التقدرا عند محاور جنوب دونيت وانها
ايضا صدت عده محاولات اوكرانيه لاستعاده
المواقع التي خسرتها لكن القوات الروسيه
اجبرت القوات المهاجمه على التراجع ايضا
الدفاع الروسيه تحدثت عنها هجمات الناجحه
واستهدافات وصفاتها بالناحه للقوات
الروسيه في اا لمانسكو كريسماس تحديدا
وقالت ان الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه اسقطت
الطائره مقاتله اوكرانيه واخرى طائره
هليكوبتر ايضا شكرا جزيلا لك السلام خضر
مراسلتنا في دنيا